[Music]
[Music]
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
you people like me I want to say that I
want to go everybody needs a bad guy you
need you guys need me
yeah and then and then I just go and I
pull out and you think it's going to be
like a swords or guns and instead it's
just [ __ ] no it's two doves that I
release I'm a man of peace now everybody
no no watch trust me trust me and then
be like oh man and then I go how about
some candy and they're like what the
[ __ ] this guy's the greatest they get
close I go and how about grenades yes
right got him got him
so there it is there it is ladies and
gentlemen what you been up to Pal well
buddy um let's see uh had a wedding
party as you know
um watch the elections it seems that do
you watch them I know I I follow them
and I listen podcast you know it's so
long they're like literally they're all
night yeah when you start I'll watch the
presidential one that one's fun but like
for this and this one I should pay no I
don't watch it I don't watch that it
will start at whatever three and end at
like three in the morning yes no no no
I'll see how it's going but it was not
it's more of a it was a red trickle
couple things
one is that and I said this the
Republicans way overshot their Mark with
this Roe v Wade things because young
women who are married were like hold on
number one you want people to have
you're gonna make me have a baby [ __ ]
off number two people like me even a 55
year old men where I heard that some of
these guys are saying under no under no
exception so if you get raped you have
incest then you have to have that baby I
go [ __ ] off Oh you mean that's it people
didn't jump on board with taking away
women's rights right right I got a huge
issue with this right before midterm
yeah an independent voters did yeah but
the thing is to be it's like I'm not the
one who was like it's about to be a red
freaking wedding baby I was joking
around here but everybody the reason I
said this because you guys told me that
not the Republicans and Democrats I'm
gonna tell you why even the Democrats
are like it's our fault I'm gonna tell
you what happened I'll tell you what
happened so then what happened was Mr
did all the Republicans the traditional
Republicans or traditional conservatives
they did well that the Republicans they
were like Trump or die election denial
they [ __ ] ate a dick and most of them
weren't that experienced Mehmet Oz was
basically a TB personality and a doctor
doctor but the my thing is like you guys
hated Dr Oz so much you vote for that
guy compromised even the words I mean
well also I mean hey hey I mean Biden's
but Jordan Peterson compared to him like
this guy's literally can't that's what I
mean but also you're also putting you're
also putting but the Republicans are
putting bad candidates Herschel Walker
he was a great football player but I
don't think he's the best [ __ ]
candidate can we do a little better but
he was a trump loyalist yes okay now
he's in it he's in a runoff it's gonna
be I go to run off of December 6th we'll
see and that'll be very significant to
see who takes over the Senate but what's
what's what I think is interesting is
that what they didn't and see if you can
guess this so the polls right what
didn't they what didn't they count on
it's really interesting polls call
people on their cell phone right
[Music]
people under 30 don't answer any calls
from a from a from a [ __ ] number they
don't recognize yeah so they didn't get
the 30-something under I mean you became
I have a block of mine exactly if I
don't know the number it's blocked so
nobody's gonna be like well there's a
703 number hello I'm not doing
absolutely interested either exactly
especially the young kid generation
we're not trusting that and so that was
the code it used to be you called the
landline they don't do that anymore of
course because somebody has a landline
now they call cell phones but only old
people answer their cell phones so all
the pollsters according to what I've
read were getting skewed data
mail uh ballots to help out you know
yeah but then also I'll tell you who had
the best night of all is DeSantis
DeSantis dude double double digits the
third largest state in the Union and the
[ __ ] won by 20 points he got
elected by a half a point dude yeah
that's the thing years ago he won by
half a point now he's doubled you know
one double dish and what they said he
won in Dade County was a republican one
there in Forever so then I even heard
the Dem I'll go back and forth you know
damn's right
man if we had to pick one this the
Santa's guys like even dem's like that's
kind of what a president looks like yeah
obviously for the Republicans he's the
representative and I was hearing um
someone very close to Trump say this
they go he he's similar to Trump as the
way he operates as far as like his you
know what he believes in in certain
policies they go but do you realize how
much smarter he is he's very eloquent
and he's not like he's not going to have
that ego where that go let's attack the
dams he wants to bring the country
together when I see him like holy that
is a that's a problem when's the last
time with a president like that that's a
president that's a president now here's
the problem he can't beat Trump in the
primaries because nobody I disagree but
nobody votes in the primaries the
problem is the Trump Fanatics will vote
I think maybe now maybe if you start if
you if the narrative is hey guys you got
to vote in the primaries to get Trump
out of there correct now because people
don't like Trump no but on both sides
right because he's so polarizing he
divides the nation I I wouldn't vote for
him in that aspect as far as someone's
policies I agree with but he's so
divisive it's not like him as a person
he's so divisive I don't like any of
them first of all the Santa's from what
I hear is one of he's like a guy's guy
but I you know I ever heard enough from
him to make a decision I think he's also
a scholar yeah but the rest of them
can suck my spotted wiener yeah they're
terrible people on both I don't like any
of them there's the you watch that like
how is this the best we have to offer
now did a homegirl win in uh Arizona uh
she was she was point two percent oh no
you know what her problem is because
she's a trump a bit of a trump election
dial
if 30 of the votes were in and she was
losing she goes there's there's fraud in
this election and literally on Fox who's
super pro red they were like whoa yeah
they're like because of the America
because of the uh tallying machines the
larger things
but here's the thing about about her too
she made a big mistake too she goes if
you like John McCain get out of here
you're [ __ ] John McCain she needs the
John McCain was super lucky if you're in
if you're if you like drama King get out
of here I don't want your vote like are
you out of your mind how does someone go
don't John McCain was an American hero
he was a great man uh yeah prison of War
and what the [ __ ] are you doing and also
you need those votes oh so dude some of
the stuff he comes out of the mouth I'm
like this is nuts yeah I like that she
goes hard on the media that's what I
like about her the song but again I
don't know anything about either but
when I watch her I'm like I'm yeah
that's cool yeah she's kind of she was
hard in the pain I respect that bring
her up when she I don't know her policy
she's probably very she's still
attractive and I like the way she speaks
very clear did you see desantis's side
like Main Chick don't say side I know
yeah
yeah she's she's very very pretty I
don't do your hair like that but it's
better when it's short well let the hair
that that's you know what's funny it's
the 80s that's the 80s
that's the 80s she's really grown into
much better looking woman yeah who's
she's beasty though but again because I
like that people that push back and then
her joke oh I'll do an interview on CNN
plus all right you got my vote that's
what it takes I'm so dumb I see that and
I'm like I like her I'm I'm just as dumb
as any voter I criticize I am just as
dumb as any voter record I think oh
we're all stupid including them but what
I think is interesting is with that Dr
Ross right like dude like come on come
on what are you doing you're not even a
real doctor and then the guy yeah he
kind of is and then the guy he was
running against fetterman
Hebrew listen I I cover up my tattoos on
stage when when when you have Obama and
Joe Biden could you cover up no his
thing is do you have to have to go his
thing is to wear a hoodie and be one
with the people but he also had a stroke
and he you know somebody made this joke
it's not a good joke I I don't I feel
bad for him well let's see he sounds
like bad Wi-Fi because he's he's coming
in and out you know I just [ __ ] up he
sounds like a dial-up internet but that
is true it sounds like develop internet
he's he's recovering from a stroke it's
no joke no but here's I'm listen I'm not
putting fun at anyone that uh has a
stroke or has a speech impediment I have
one myself and I didn't have a stroke
but according to him here's the thing if
if you're if you're not a brilliant
person you know what I'm saying and
speaks well and you're a man for the
people you don't run for politics if
you're compromised yeah and we I thought
yeah listen Dr Ozzy listen you know a
bit of batshit crazy but I thought Dr Oz
was gonna win just because they're like
all right well it's this guy who at the
debates like literally have to have read
from a thing and mess that up or the Oz
guy I guess we'll go with Oz yeah but no
that this just shows people like uh-uh
dude again oz big Trump guy right yes I
think society's pushing back going we're
good on that well also Oz wasn't from
Pennsylvania and also when he was he was
uh he this is what I would do this is
where I would go wrong he's [ __ ]
shopping in Wegmans which Wegmans is a
bit like when you go to Pennsylvania
Department Store no it's a it's a a
grocery store like Ralph's okay so
everybody knows Wegmans you know and I
think you pronounce it a certain way I
think it's Wegmans anyway it's a big
deal so he's there and he goes I'm gonna
I'm gonna go shopping and I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go look at how much prices are
because they're out of touch so he's
[ __ ] he's going through the store and
he goes and he goes um
he he goes look at this I'm shopping for
crew today for my wife and it's twenty
dollars I mean that doesn't go with
tequila and and everybody in
Pennsylvania is like what the [ __ ] is
she's like these scallops what the
[ __ ] like yeah crudites a French word
dude it's it's when you chop raw
vegetables up and you have it as a dip
yes don't say it's criticated no one in
Pennsylvania my my girls my my wife's
family's from Pennsylvania they go to
Wawas and they get themselves [ __ ]
hoagies and Wawa's coffee yeah they are
Americans we'll get some bagels don't
don't start talking if I was like Hey
guys let's have some crudies today
they'd all look at me like who brought
the Communist here no Dr Oz was like I'm
one of you guys you guys have any Pate
here and they're like you're on wagons
bro yeah hey that's exactly right it's
insane it's like you guys are insane
they're all insane enough right insane
also though [ __ ] he he Oprah made him
and she came out against him yeah well
she didn't mess with her applicants
right yeah Helix you spend most of your
time in bed Brennan okay you need a
personalized mattress oh dude and in
this weather Daddy's sleeping so hard
and I like to think it's the weather but
it's my mattress my Helix Sleep mattress
there's so much to have in my house 14
unique mattresses including a collection
of luxury models a mattress for Big and
Tall like yourself yeah for kids it's
even a mattress yep it'll sleep on it
yep T sleeps on a a helix Sleep mattress
take the Helix sleep quiz they will tell
you what mattress is good for your body
and your personalized mattress is ships
straight to your door free of charge
you're gonna love it so much they
they're so confident they have a hundred
night risk-free trial but you're gonna
love it so don't worry about it yeah
sleep better for 100 nights yep take the
quiz they're going to give you the
perfect matches for your thick self plus
Helix mattress are American made and
come with a 10 to 15 year warranty
depending on the model all right and
remember you get tried out 109th risk
free if you don't listen free but you're
well and they'll even pick it up for a
full refund don't worry about it man so
if you want to try out the best mattress
on the market Helix is offering you guys
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for the listeners and viewers of
fighter and the kid go to helixsleep.com
fighter with Helix better sleep starts
now
athletic green oh I love it is ag-1
here's the thing every day I take you
buddy you get your you basically get in
one tasty scoop 75 vitamins minerals
Whole Foods Source ingredients
multivitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and More in one
conveniently serving I actually know a
billionaire who who takes it every
morning I looked at him I was like what
is that he goes That's athletic greens I
go how do you know about that because I
think I heard about it on your podcast
you know too many billionaires right
they invest in high quality reputable
sources of each ingredient okay they go
above and beyond in third-party testing
to ensure their customers continue to
receive the highest quality best daily
nutritional habits on the planet yeah I
use it as a multivitamin join the
movement of athletes life lights moms
dads podcasters Comics first timers
everybody doing it to make it easy
athletic greens can give you immune
supporting free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel facts
with your first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com fighter again all you
got to do is go to athleticgreens.com
fighter to take control of your health
and give ad1 a try
I'm interested to see what happens in LA
and then also in New York it was a lot
closer and there were some counties that
went Red Like New York is starting to
flip a little bit Yeah and then in
California pretty close to carusoe it's
still going on I think Caruso may win
that'll be uh having a he's a he's
technically a Democrat but he's a way
more conservative Democrat he's not a
far left and he's also not a [ __ ]
He's also not an entrenched government
bureaucrat with long ties to the
government he's a [ __ ] billionaire
developer yeah my man gets [ __ ] done he
knows the thing or two about making some
moony yeah I like somebody who made
Mooney I like when you made Mooney
because then you realize that there's a
way to balance the budget yes and then
do you care about the economy and other
businesses to make Mooney yeah it makes
Mooney so right there he's up right now
damn barely though dude yeah this is
surprised it's still early it was at 30
44 of the vote still early with the
mail-in ballots usually Dems come that's
pretty impressive this early 44 oh watch
it all night and then finally I was
watching my kids like that what is this
[ __ ] I'm like it's this will make a
difference for us
that's the thing like Herschel Walker
lose it and like the Senate the house
overall yeah because we travel yeah for
for where we live yeah we need Caruso to
win yeah that's all you should care well
what's local politics are what affects
your everyday life yeah but the problem
is that like what actually so there's no
parent Revolt there was no [ __ ] um
covid no Reckoning for covid there was
no like the same uh DA's that are soft
on crime are still there you know what's
interesting yeah with your point about
covet yeah the places that locked well
la right now is looking different but
the other ones that really locked down
yeah they still won the copenhites
because we have short-term memories yeah
because now it's about inflation safety
which is right but even crime like a lot
of a lot of the DA's and stuff are still
but but I do think like these major blue
States like you know New York and La
that's definitely getting closer it's
only a matter of time yeah if they keep
going on this path but Democrats that's
no they can't keep going down this path
like they're def this scared them enough
we're like all right that was close it
wasn't a red wedding but that [ __ ] was
pink it was pink it was painting it was
definitely a it was that rare blue
Toonami and a red wave yeah that [ __ ]
with me well they both canceled each
other and I asked for rare in the way
hey [ __ ] you didn't mean well you're
getting you mean well you did well
medium well medium medium plus yeah you
get me you ain't getting rare dad you
know rare there's no blood on this me
it's gonna be rare you gonna play cooked
well done [ __ ]
just coming into the hallway on top of
that we're gonna put a little blue
cheese on there yeah we'll let your blue
for you the walls will bleed a little
bit that's about it but everyone said
leaving Rogan was like Rogan you know he
got backlash he was like it's gonna be
like that movie in The Shining where
they open up the doors it's just red
yeah but again and you know Rogue is one
of the smartest guys that we know but
you know we're not politics we're not in
we're not Poli SCI Majors we're we're
not in this scene oh but I'm getting it
from other major sources even the Dems
were like we're [ __ ] I listened to a
podcast called commentary magazine
podcast they are coming body commentary
magazine podcast Tommy's our first
podcast for us podcast and all they do
is follow [ __ ] politics like nerds
get deep in the weeds they write for Max
yeah sometimes it's fun yeah they're
pollsters and all of them had all of
them this morning were like we are all
humbled we're all humbled now are they
far-right people or whatever they're
they're they're they're it's
surprisingly they're actually
almost all Jewish are all Jewish and
they're conservative Jews it's kind of a
weird thing it's like their thing you're
all you're actually going far right but
they did live stream from storm in the
capital but they're in the middle no but
they're they're not they're not I guess
they're more right than they are left
but they're more likely in the middle
they're more in the middle I'd say yeah
and um but they're [ __ ] smart super
smart and all of them were like hey man
we've all been humbled we looked at
every poll we looked at all the [ __ ]
things and guess what
people are different polls can be skewed
and for the most part you don't know
what the [ __ ] is going to happen until
it happens and the fact that these young
like college students or these people
who are young they're just unpredictable
well none of that but also they're not
voting either but they also don't want
to deal with this abortion [ __ ] when I
saw that Rojo ad I was like you
Republicans are gonna pay for this
because young people are like I that's
what they're activated this was a
settled issue and you the the also think
about the Press on that being the pre
even the Press on that Roe versus Wade
staff the Press hit even the Millennials
the young like we all heard about it no
matter what you're watching MTV your
favorite celebrities uh tweeting you're
posting about Anthony so that was really
in their face so to them like oh
republican remember what the Supreme
Court said about Roe v Wade they said
guys it's not actually up for us it
doesn't matter right because it is a
state issue it's not a constitutional
issue so now I went to the states and if
you look at the States including in
Kentucky conservative places there was
[ __ ] there's no doubt that people
Americans were like
I don't like wearing a condom [ __ ] off
I'm gonna make mistakes and I don't want
to have to deal with this so abortion
should be Loops yeah
I'm pregnant yeah but also our taxes are
where condoms yeah yeah all of us like
uh lockdowns are attacks or condoms all
right well inflation crime hate that I
don't wear a condom [ __ ] that I don't
want to be locked down to California
yeah but again with California we Cruise
so you know that'd be a big one oh yeah
big one that's a big one
um my horse won the race though Doug
whatever you do don't ask me what I had
to do this morning whatever you do don't
say Brian don't do it what'd you do this
well not you you weren't doing a photo
shoot for socks I was not doing a photo
shoot for socks no no propellers on
there now here's the thing you're 55. I
know but son has the same [ __ ] ran
out of sake walkies okay so Daddy had to
go into the drawer of the orphan socks
you know the one that one pair yeah is
it my turn today yeah that's all I got
yeah is it my turn and you're always
like [ __ ] off no is it my turn finally I
was like [ __ ] so what did that
just a little son of a [ __ ]
well Daddy uh you know my friends over
at rapid Health Dan Garner
and very smart guys scientists said
right
you've given us a lot of business we're
gonna look under your hood for free and
I went you [ __ ] I love you so
they're looking under the hood Daddy had
to take now you got to send in your
saliva you gotta sin in your blood and
poo poo hold on yeah hold on
can I hold on soft serve you gotta send
in your saliva you got to stand in your
blood you got to send in your urine you
got a jackal no I didn't no they would
probably take that nothing was different
um but they then said
you gotta poo into this tray yep and use
the spoon God damn it use the wooding
it's so disgusting you gotta get you
gotta scoop it into these little tubes
yeah so Daddy has a squat like a [ __ ]
dog
in this bathroom with a little tray and
and that smells good right that smells
good that's a great season no matter how
fast you close the lid oh my God also
I'm good I'm good I was gonna say I'm
good a lot of this stuff you know I
stopped after that I did the same thing
yeah and then when they told me she's in
the cup I tried I went I don't care
you know what no it's on the house no I
got it I'm good I almost did I almost
went I think I'd rather die of something
I don't know about than have to do this
my thing is is like from all the other
stuff in the blood and the saliva and
all that can you just tell me about that
stuff
with the [ __ ] I'm good well they want to
look at your gut I'm good they want to
look at your bacteria I'd rather no come
on man I'd rather no and on the form it
said on the Forum it goes
worm if you get a worm take it out and
keep it separately in a separate tube I
was like well thank God I don't have any
[ __ ] worms
you should respond back what if there's
multiple alarms when you live overseas
the way I did in the 70s oh I had some
worms in your butt my daughter my
daughter my sister and me had gold worms
small ones like the size of like Earth
when you lived overseas when you were me
in India Pakistan Lebanon places like
that you got things like hepatitis A you
got [ __ ] like worms I mean real worms
coming out your [ __ ] I mean I'm
talking about like earthworms yes I'm
talking about pink worms that are coming
out of your ass look up worms in your
ass like that [ __ ] not tapeworms I feel
sick please take that off very common by
the way very common no it's not no in
most before yeah third world yeah before
we had [ __ ]
you know stop the hygiene and we had got
the sewage like you know hookworms were
a major major problem in the United
States one of the turning points in
American history was when uh Americans
stopped using outhouses and started
getting underground indoor facilities oh
my gosh hookworms let me tell you what
hookworms do the hook oh my God so many
so many [ __ ] rural places in the
South had hookworms okay now you see
that right ah it's worms on my feet now
when I say entire towns had it that's
what would happen because you'd be in
bare feet and you'd walk can you just
cut them out [ __ ] you take a [ __ ]
somewhere and they didn't even have
outhouses you take a [ __ ] in the out
great outdoors the problem was that
that's where worms breed okay now when
you get a hook in your skin well they
they go they they have an egg in your
[ __ ] an egg in your foot and now how
about this my friend how about this sir
then go there how do people get
hookworms infection is mainly acquired
by walking barefoot on contaminated soil
one kind of organelles will be
transmitted through the ingestion of
larvae most people in fact with
hookworms have no symptoms some have
gastrointestinal symptoms especially
people who are infected the first time
yeah go to click on down how do humans
get rid of here's what they do though
here's what they do they get ultimately
into your intestine
and for whatever reason you have trouble
absorbing iron and then you become
anemic and then you have no energy
that's if you do nothing entire towns
yes but back in the day entire towns in
the South would just be sitting around
because they had no energy and then
you'd die yeah they pass away yeah well
you know uh chicks I want to lose weight
would put a tapeworm down the throat
it's a myth but I like what you're
saying should bring it up Jen it's a
myth but I like I don't think it's ever
happened I don't but I appreciate what
you're saying and I like that you just
said that now promise I know you
promised and I know you're going to
promise now woman puts tapeworm down her
sure throat sure somebody puts the
tapeworm weight loss side effects yeah
every human needs to do eating tapeworms
for weight loss is it risky and illegal
yeah Iowa woman tries tapeworm diet I'm
telling you it's literally a thing it's
a thing now listen
Maybe not maybe being an influencer is
not for you if the way you got to lose
weight is eating well I'm kind of liking
this now because you're you're this
actually happened I'm educating I'm
educating you that is the most
disgusting thing no now how do you do
that is this a parody site no no no no
no no no no it's all over you've never
heard of it Mark I'm telling you it's
all over kid there'll be several people
that have done it so far you know how
long they can get look at that there's
several people have done 30 feet long
yeah several 30 feet long in your
[ __ ] intestines look at that I woman
tries to eat there you go and that's USA
Today
uh I don't know swallowing a yeah I
don't think I don't think you can give
yourself a table no you can't you know
you can't yeah these hubs are doing it
listen they're trying to make Bank bro
hold on try to make them mooning she
bought a tape where I'm off the internet
swallowed it dropped it and then in
order to drop a few pounds do you think
you could just hit the treadmill I think
it's probably uh worse than being all
right
to her doctor and she bought it
swallowed it the woman's doctor on
somebody wasn't sure what to do it
sister
and Justin Hayward extremely risk and
cause a wide range of undesirable side
effects of course including rare deaths
look look that this is usually like so
the beef tapeworm is used in these sorts
of Quick Weight Loss schemes in the late
1900s late 19th and early 20th century
centuries advertisement padded sanitized
tapeworms as a weapon against fat the
enemy that is shortening your life
that is [ __ ] crazy oh look at this
more recent report surferred that
dieters in Hong Kong were swallowing
tapeworms lose weight and 2009 Tyra
Banks did an episode over talk show in
which She interviewed women multiple
women said they would be willing to
swallow a tapeworm if it really meant
they could easily drop a few pounds
I can't think of anything more
disgusting
yeah I don't know though that the
tapeworm lives and it would develop it
does tapeworms will cause you to lose
weight because you have this huge
warming intestines eating your food
huh yeah these people are doing dies
otherwise there's no [ __ ] story yeah
the more you know God damn it
how about to educate Eric Griffin Chris
DeLeon uh the goal now yesterday because
they bribed George Washington I was like
you know you never that's all you know
that's a metaphor him cutting down the
apple tree and you know his teeth
weren't wooden right and Eric used to be
a school teacher and he was dude you
can't be spending this information
oh no Eric I'm telling you just look it
up he's like bro where'd you find this
at Alex Jones went no just Google it
dude his teeth he had several sets of
teeth then he got some from slaves yes
he paid them for me and steal them but
I'm from slaves he took their teeth out
put them in his teeth he's like bro
that's insanely okay and Chris is like
dude you got to stop your chin bring it
up sure enough for me too all over all
over dude yeah and that sounds insane I
thought they were wooden teeth until I
spoke to you about it yeah we brought it
up no chopped on the apple tree
wasn't that Abraham Lincoln anyway no
it's George Washington
was it wait the George cherry tree is
George Washington right I thought it was
Abe Lincoln which president and what was
the myth about the chair parrot cherry
tree he chopped it out that he chopped
it down and then somebody asked him if
he did because he wasn't supposed to
George Washington and uh
but but Abe Lincoln
so I don't know if there's an associate
that's a mess
what did Abe Lincoln chop down
besides the tree of slavery
right I mean you don't want to start
with uh Abe Lincoln is gay he made it
yeah
this and this isn't like some Sam triple
Eddie bro he had his security would
sleep with him at night instead of his
wife oh dude why oh I don't have the
imagination to pick this up I don't have
an imagination let me explain something
to you dude I better sleep with him
I'm an American I have nothing people
who are gay but I need to stop spreading
it was different back then from
socialistrust.com that was different
back then you can't go to gaysrus.com
and then look up Abe Lincoln okay
sex with Mary Todd many times they had
about five children one day most of them
who died all of them died actually it's
terrible eventually all of them did it's
so sad she went crazy she ended up in a
mental institution but either way just
be crazy either way dude [ __ ] be
crazy even better take it back or I'm
gonna give you a surf and turf what's it
well you can try and give me that
communist surf and turf I can give you
the facts it comes right here and right
here what do you want what do you want
this is the United States dude I'm gonna
lock you up
I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
hey so just so you know hey you're right
what I do when I fight critics lives
homosexualized that Lincoln married had
four children Scholars write that link I
can't understand you hey man are you
Charlie Brown's mother are you Charlie
Brown's mother right now through it okay
let me just see a critics of the
hypothesis of the hypothesis that
Lincoln was homosexual emphasize that
Lincoln married and had four children
that means nothing scholar Douglas
Wilson writes at Lincoln
robustly heterosexual Behavior robust
including telling stories to his friends
of his interactions with women no no
he's not gay he told a story yeah oh
okay but then he slept with his security
guard every night I just cause that's
what they did Sir then because you know
what though I'm with you sir because
that's so normal that's what hetero says
because you don't want to sleep alone
back then your security guard sleeps
with you make sure nobody breaks into
your house yeah Jack the Ripper on the
loose back then even though he's in
England
America a psychologist is an influential
gay writer and former sex research
researcher tries to resolve the issue of
Lincoln's sexuality once more for all
there you go his conclusion is that the
America's greatest president the beacon
of the Republican party was a gay man 10
years of his research 10 years he
dedicated his life before he died all
right the last year in his book we Are
Lincoln men
um Mr Tripp okay a lot of gay books here
um in previous multi-volume Edition okay
multi volumes guys month by month tax
and bundles of fact alleged I found
invisible companionships that surprised
me past a few of these presents lurked
and remember in this book okay dude um
homosexual cut 1954. yep he cut it out
of the book so he was gay he was called
Gay because he was against slavery
exactly what well guys back then were
like white white races were like the
guy's gay he's against slavery for
business
extreme privacy accounts by those who
knew him well he was not very fond of
girls he thought they were gross
that doesn't say that dude it does he
thought that he doesn't say he thought
he gave her gross the only thing thing
we have on record Lincoln's saying about
women is oh no no dude you're [ __ ]
paraphraged I'm reading it right now you
guys he's not reading that man
says we are Lincoln men the book Mr
Donald wrote that no one at the time
ever suggested that he and speed were
sexual partners yes
hurden ready who sometimes slept in the
room with him never met a sexual
relationship you can't back then maybe
he is ready for this the space was tight
in the men's shirt beds back then that's
what you do they weren't lovers all
right yeah
um I slept with Joshua for four years
slept with Joshua's security guy for
four years if they were lovers Miss John
wrote Lincoln would have spoken to me
wouldn't have spotted I doubt that
exactly he wouldn't have back then so
guess what dude guess what you know what
I don't like you know I don't like what
I don't like your homophobic I'm not
being home what's wrong with one of the
greatest presidents the United States
they're sleeping with a security guard
thing and licking his butt there's
nothing wrong with that the board saying
is that there's didn't have TV back then
there's it's what they'd have music it's
white plantation owners were probably
like he's so gay he's against slavery I
can just see them nah back then that's
not the way they talk that's how
heterosexual races talk they go you're
[ __ ] you're not into slavery you must
be gay yeah but you know back then it's
like you know all right so you put your
lean on your buddy's dick butt you know
you put your ween in your buddy's butt
it's back it's back in the day if you
sleep with a man you sleep with him and
then even if you got Kylie but what are
you gonna do send a pigeon note well
there's no heat there's no heat so you
use you bloody's blood well first of all
there's not a lot of places to sleep no
that's what they say it's a tight
quarters that's what that security guard
said he goes listen what's up here four
years tight quarters there's tight
quarters but you were the president
United States right yeah I know but they
don't give them five-star Resorts all
the time no sometimes it's very tight
quarters we're sleeping nuts to butts no
it was the Durham president because he
he was that security and first of all
I'm sure they slept
foot to feet I mean head to foot never
that's not warm that's not warm you had
to find I don't know the legs legs are
not warm the feet you see but Nest to
butt you can still [ __ ] that way
69. well if my head's down there
yeah and your butt's there my dick is
still close to your butt
yeah you're good you understand what I'm
saying you know what that doesn't get
gay it's not face to face that's what
I'm saying so I'm holding on I see what
you're doing I'm holding your feet and
I'm going pee you
um
your toes around my mouth yeah it was
very dirty you know what I'm saying big
old [ __ ] time Lincoln had some you're
like this you're like this I'm ticklish
yeah I'm like straight still [ __ ]
station yeah this isn't gay yeah you're
right dude that's what you have to do
back then that's keeping warm snuggle up
dude let's keep it warm
and then you know Lee had a high-pitched
boys yeah I was like Hey Hey Y'all four
score seven years ago hey y'all so I I'm
like slavery I once wrote so uh the
writer for
um what was that the the presidency show
with uh no it's the one before yeah I
did the writers from West Wing got cut
out um
I thought it was going to be a recurring
he wrote this play on Lincoln that has
all the stuff you're including in there
you have to make this up I I was
tutoring one of his kids and he had me
write a rap for the ending of it so I'd
like read through the play and summarize
all the stuff is true like and it might
not be indisputable but like the gay
stuff and the high voice stuff and
there's like it's a really interesting
point where like there's all these I
have no doubts three things it's like we
can't even figure out I have no doubt
there are a lot of questions so old
school okay I mean it could be I mean
yeah but also back then no you know I'm
not judge I don't I literally don't give
a [ __ ] but also back then it was like
you know just you know but just the
basics
back then than it is now sir but um back
then you go to war you don't keep it
you're with the Bros yeah you had to
keep it Mighty oh okay you know it's
like going to prison now he's not gay if
you hook up there's more religion people
were worried they would go to hell they
committed the sin yeah not really but
then also with this we remember the
Spartans like they had little boys that
would suck them off there was a lot of
there's a lot of Greece wealthy guys had
young boys
and homosexuality was essentially it was
basically accepted yeah Jack them off
feed them grapes whatever it is if you
if you had like you [ __ ] boys you
[ __ ] young yeah like and you had your
women yeah and you were married yeah
yeah interesting
sort of you know at least maybe the
elites or maybe Socrates and played
maybe they were just a gay and super
smart and it was a it was a gay group
who just I think back then and also
maybe it wasn't as bad back then right
like there's no social media you wasn't
really getting out yeah well he was like
broke Back Mountain like when they were
out on their own on the Prairie back
there no one knew I know that one guy
was like oh hell no but you know what
like as a straight dude I mean there are
sexuality Spectrum but even if I am on
the Prairie and there are no women
around you guys I'm not [ __ ] it's
never gone through my no mine now now if
there's a a warlock that's you know some
the only chick yeah and you're out there
for about two years around the Bros and
then one day she decides yeah I'm so
dirty from all this horse oh yeah and
she jumps in that River yeah damn is
that that's right he looks like Megan
Fox you're having sex after two oh yeah
I mean it is for about a month maybe one
week I go look at my business you get it
yeah hey be cool yeah let's not tell any
Tales when we get back no maybe maybe
one you know I'd be worried about you
and your your chatty mouth you're in 300
you're the guy with the eye Patchwork
what I go to war and I go go tell my
story [ __ ] oh yeah you're that guy yeah
but you're even like you might get well
I I had a guy I had a guy who was super
smart and I remember that we were
talking about gay stuff in high school
and he was like an older class and it
was college and he was like a senior and
it was a sexuality class something I
remember he said uh well you know they
were saying can straight men be gay I'm
listening and he said you know there are
times when you can experience tremendous
kinship with another man and that can
spark a a an intimate uh expression and
he was really articulate about that and
I'm sitting there watching I'm listening
to him and then I I remember like I I
marked I clocked that and then over the
next year or two I had incredible
incredible feelings of kinship with
friends like drunk like just laugh
having a great time and not once no
you're leaving a few details no no do
you have an erection I did not have an
erection maybe you couldn't do it even
if I did have a directions for someone
else maybe no because I remember my I've
had that my buddy Ray buratti and my Ray
Brianna and my myself looking at him
going I love this guy we're having such
a great time not once you're like I want
to suck yeah you know what dude's mouth
I want to suck you yeah I didn't want to
go hey I'll make out with you never no
but the end people that do it good for
you man that's probably I know Society
that's what I'm saying you either have
it in here you don't it's no big deal
yeah you're wired that way yeah I don't
care it's probably easier you know you
and your buddy yeah you're about you're
just you're broken start having a hard
time I I think gay men my prediction on
the transgender stuff yeah my prediction
on the transgender stuff is you're gonna
have a [ __ ] load of lawsuits and a [ __ ]
load already are of 18 19 year old now
women they're going to be who are
exhibiting feminine traits we're
encouraged to go through hormonal and it
was okay by society yet well not just
that a whole medical establishment
that's what I'm saying and and they are
going to go you guys put me on puberty
blockers I I now have a micro penis or
no penis and I have and I'm a woman and
I'm suicidal because I'm stuck in this
body that you guys yeah yeah so so how
many gay men are we gonna do that too
young boys who are exhibiting I guess
what you would consider feminine
characteristics that are then
interpreted as oh you're a girl and he
says I am a girl I guess I'm uh I'm
really young now there may be one
transgender child in one million that we
help with that kind of thing how many
gay how many future games dicey road we
don't know yet [ __ ] we don't know yet
we're in the leather helmets well we
should know because one thing that we
don't know is that kids don't know
they're saying I agree they don't know
how to certain we know that for a fact
yes certainly so give kids some time I
think they're going to go down a weird
rabbit hole with that I think there's
going to be some lawsuits open with
social media I think that's just a
matter of time for people to start doing
for social media certain for the kids
yeah it's horrible it's going to come
with addictive warning right so I think
there's be lawsuits all over that and
then I you know I think eventually UFC
could see headed their way too well
there let me ask you guys this everybody
in this room so there are two those are
the three so different things but you
know what I'm saying yeah but there are
two things lawsuits like like so for
Democrats
when when liberals start talking about
the transgender stuff and kids they lose
me and I'm totally against it I think
most Americans I think most Americans
when you start talking about biological
men and female sports I'm totally
against it but most Americans be left
and right I have no I'm not compromising
with you I I think you're a radical and
you're my enemy and if that's your
agenda you're not getting my vote no
matter if I line with everything else
I'm out now here's my other problem then
then you get Republicans that are super
super right-wing liberal I mean
religious who say uh abortion abortion
is bad under all circumstances at the
minute there's a heartbeat and if
there's rape or incest we don't care are
the kids something I'm out you know
you're not getting my vote on either
side those that those two things are not
yet I can't compromise on it I'm out and
most of us are that way I want middle
most Americans are that way but it's a
bummer the things we have to pick and
choose because the smartest people
aren't running for politics like who
would want that job you'll be a
narcissist you have to be crazy Rich
right like there's so many boxes then
you've been to have a clean history you
better want to be a politician since you
were [ __ ] five because if you got
frisky in middle school and high school
it's coming well it's coming Mr Trump Mr
Trump and you have all the money look
what Biden look what Biden [ __ ]
weathered though oh my God Biden that
the lives the lies that made us in the
80s the early 80s about being at the top
of his class I love that you know about
this stuff because that's crazy you
don't know this is
not everybody knows it oh yeah because
Biden's such this like oh he's so
lovable but every politician has a
selfie no one brings it up literally the
biggest lies right and then Cokey
Roberts and all that and I remember I
used to watch this show called The
McLaughlin group and it was very popular
on Sundays and all of them said no he's
finished he's done he's done he'll never
come back and then on top of that then
he had his own sexual uh allegation
Scandal yeah but it's like but then
president but not and then as president
your son is in collusion In Cahoots with
Russia the Chinese yeah and you know
what I'm saying but both of them like
all of it like literally in the middle
of it and they're just like hey man it
is what it is all good every president
has their dark history I mean you're
going to Bill Clinton insane Hillary
Clinton this is not what are we talking
about here sir what are we talking about
sir
sir that's the magic mine sir the magic
I can't play Magic mine turns me into
don't blame the magic Jones no no like
it takes over my brain and then just
these little things oh
all right but I'm gonna have to
have to just just to Intrigue the
audience chin I'm gonna have to have you
delete that I mean not that I want you
to beep that part and let the audience
guess what he said okay
hey those are cutie patootie shoes
yeah the pink sockies they're so dirty
on the bottom because I walked outside
yesterday Barefoot in the rain oh boy
and then how about that rain
you know what we need to say it we need
it my dad when I was young it triggers
me man we need it it's a cleanser I was
like this do we though we're in Denver
the aquifer there's so much I like
people [ __ ] snow well the aquifiers
are dry have you checked the aquifiers
we need it what is an aquifer I don't
even [ __ ] know I'll tell you what
Daddy sleeps hard in this way it's a
little cold I leave the window open and
that rain's trickling God snug these
things are hard oh man but I got a baby
and baby starts to is he not sleeping
through the night yet not really but I I
bring him in I'm a softy I I snuggle up
with that one I don't have to I don't
care I bring them right there there's
nothing more than cuddling he wakes up
and smiles at me I look up and he's
looking at me like that you can't have a
bad day oh that day that's why every
morning I I get butterflies with him for
my kids like bossy wakes up at five my
girl like God damn it leave him in them
like not a chance because I'll I'll
change them right you can hear them
talking oh we have a modern he'll go
Daddy I'm awake
the greatest thing the best ever when he
calls for me I'm like point right Point
[ __ ] he's asking for me but then the
you know it is like the other day he's
going Daddy I'm awake and my girl's like
leave him he needs to know he can't wake
up at five in the morning I'm like but
I'm up who gives a [ __ ] like I'm down to
do this she has no because when you're
gone about five I don't want to give it
five so I'm like I'm we're arguing right
and Daddy I'm away then he's singing for
30 minutes singing doing his thing one
two he can count so he likes to show off
count and he goes Daddy I'm awake [ __ ]
I swear to God
Daddy I'm awake [ __ ] I could not stop
laughing I said my girl goes you have to
stop close around the kids what if he
does this what if he does at school I go
a to be hilarious B what are they gonna
do he knows he doesn't know what he's
saying it's hilarious I hope he does it
awesome it's so funny and then she's
like yeah tell him stop so the next
morning I woke up because I wanted to
record it that thing would go so viral
and I was like okay he's going Daddy I'm
awake my girl this go get him like no no
let's see because she's he's not gonna
do I told him not to him like you you
[ __ ] me I could use this to sell
tickets yeah I need to shout out to him
daddy I'm awake [ __ ] that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
so funny it is hilarious but no I I get
them I change them then we go downstairs
I post the video I think it was
yesterday 5 30 in the morning Daddy Boom
Boom Pow boxing less boxing lives oh
dude I'm like bro I'm like dude it's
five I kicked and throw he can throw
yeah that's kid concerning me so then he
does this be when I go all right I'll go
down we gotta do Spiderman and just the
worst Spiderman he goes like this
there's a little Spiderman gets his
shoulders all high but he's a beast now
now um oh you put this kid took my
workshop I'm so proud yeah
I mean he's amazing
he can [ __ ] hit though oh man he
lights his brother up does he I'm like T
he got another year before he can let
him get these three shots buddy watch
this watch the way he throws watch this
look at that that's a very good punch
it's early and I I tell you the longest
thing was Prejudice he's thrown with
prejudice dudes oh you should see him
hit his brother really yeah he loves
your brother his brother can take it
though tiger thinks it's funny and he'll
hit him like in the stomach or he's also
hit him in the wiener I'm like dude I'm
telling everybody yeah one more year
this kid starts throwing heat so but did
you so you're supposed to sleep train
kids right would you say you're supposed
to sleep train him like you leave him in
there to cry I don't do it and and I
know that other cultures like if you
talk to like people from the Philippines
or India they go where's the baby sleep
with us what are you talking about they
look at you like what are you crazy
first American thing right it's a
western it's a Western European it's a
modern
affluent
you know thing where you did you hear
the theory with your baby do you hear
you you want the one especially like you
know my buddy clop he did this research
where he's like um it builds the baby's
immune system for them to sleep in the
cold he's in Denver so he would leave
the windows open the winter so the rooms
are freezing but the kids are used to it
and they're never sick huh and I was
like well they're never sick he's like
no one since they're infants man we'd
have it cold all the time I was like man
I don't know if I believe I mean as long
as they're warm I can't have their body
being cold oh you don't believe that you
believe Hillary Clinton yeah
appreciate you coming and he's telling
me all the [ __ ] he's gone through with
his family-owned business and the way
it's affected his family and you know an
absolute psychopath shot the place up I
know do you know this I know the eating
middle of the day it's in a very nice
place in DC we'll go over in DC in
December we'll go to Cosmic Pizza
fantastic food family environment next
door is a uh you know preschool
um so but the point is oh it's tough to
navigate these Waters but the point is
he's like you want to go to the basement
I go yeah I do no I know it's fun though
right I said uh I'll go to the basement
and he opened he goes this is the only
door to the to and there was a closet
because we don't have a basement no I
mean I listen it was ridiculous you know
I did I went you did that's terrible you
can you can say anything that's terrible
so there's nothing below
pretty Hollow down there he goes what he
was okay you've had your funnel
and he goes that you've seen enough I
went yeah sure I have hey so I saw a
door with some stairs downstairs what's
that about us through keep the dough
keep the dough down there huh can I see
there he goes absolutely okay we keep
the dough I hear some kid go help and I
went hold on who's that he goes we have
kids it's a workshop we let them need
the dough okay you know I'm buying all
this because small hands are good for
making putting the pepperonis on putting
the pepperonis now pepperoni is not code
word for boys that's not it that's not
true I don't believe that at all I don't
believe it all anchovies is not a Coke
or something creating you're a rumor
mill isn't it fun though that's like
these people like it's so into
conspiracies
it does damage it's fun until one of my
followers is like he's right yeah no no
I'm going to Cosmic Pizza I'm [ __ ]
telling that guy yeah it's fun until
somebody comes in with a gun I agree oh
and harassing B all jokes aside I'm
telling us out with the owner the pain I
saw on this man's face you can't fake
that it's like when uh Alex Jones had to
sit face to face with those parents from
Sandy Hook yeah the the Al Pacino
couldn't pull that off the hurt that
those parents had when I saw that I went
I had turned off when I'm out yeah I'm
telling you I sat down with the owner
you'll meet him Mark great guy and you
could just the pain what are you going
to DC uh
yeah December 15th 17th I'll be there
I'll be at Cosmic uh Cosmos or Cosmic
Pizza autograph signing and I do sign
Hillary Clinton merch
what what she'll be there she's also
gonna be she's opening for me she has
some great amateur jokes on Carolina
Comedy Zone November 10. oh that's
tomorrow tomorrow Friday Saturday
Addison Texas
19. Naples Florida off the hook December
one two three and four West Nyack I'm
not doing any more guys I'm so sorry
Boston Massachusetts Live Boston oh yeah
fight companion on the 10th oh yeah and
we I have a fight companion on the ninth
and I'll wait for them to announce it
but signed a big deal big deal and after
next week on the ninth big deal
had an onboard meeting this morning big
deal yeah I'll tell you been trying to
get with these guys for a hospital
pitched him on the idea it took three
years to push this through well three
did it congratulations thank you sir
[ __ ] awesome every time I do a deal I
call roganoff from money
His companion says that you know we
started the original crew yeah I go hey
I want to get your beak wet he goes
those are peanuts to me Brandon yes I'd
like to do another fight companion with
Rogan and Eddie and me and you that was
fun oh that's not my bad in years yeah
I'm dead what's up that I'm dead what's
up Joe that brought that brought the
life out of me I had so much fun how
great is Eddie I just miss him as Santa
really calls him the prophet can we go
back up for a sec do you want do you
have any last minute oh you know you
don't talk to you left before he came so
on on Tuesday or I'm sorry Monday after
Friday Al Joe on so you you would love
him such a good dude such a good dude so
that drops uh tomorrow Thursday on uh
thick boy the AL Joe and he talks about
find Peter John fighting Henry sahudo
sugar Shawn who he wants out of them
I'm sure you can guess I pitched him on
who should fight he wants Henry no
wait sure Sean
oh wait give me the names sugar should
be sugar if Cheeto got another win or an
interim fight for for Cheetos he wants
sugar he wants sugar biggest name number
one right guy yeah
um we've gone over these and we have a
bit yeah we have any second five grand
bet Frankie Edgar
it's last fight last we're on mass
Square Garden
you know he's my first guest ever yes
five years ago yes on food truck I flew
to Jersey he had the best pizza the best
crust that was the best is the water
they use the New Jersey water that has
Dead Mafia guys in it that they yes I
know I'm spreading them they said that
they said the water yeah so but it's the
water they put in the pizza dough it
dude the pizza I had with them on Jersey
Shore was fantastic but that's where I
got the idea I'm like well this is so
much fun because he was so excited to
talk about the pizza and show me his
hometown I was like I can't fly to fight
his hometown what I flew them to me and
they're like well what would we do for
food every time like we're in La there's
food trucks that's future Diaries
Showtime's like let's do it and that's
how the tutorial because of Frankie's
episode that's how that thing came about
um he's my first guest ever you wanna
you want me to you want me to give you
your money what you want you want to
double down I'm done Jesus on Alex
prayer what do you can what are you
going against Dr Oz oh
that's hey that's what you're making fun
of a stroke victim no I'm not I'm making
fun making fun of a stroke who's running
for politics right huh I'm making fun of
a stroke victim that's running for
politics that's insane wow that should
not be okay if you're compromised
definitely recovery run he's recovering
yes yeah we have a ways to go yes
it's not no what's the bet you want to
make I mean we have five thousand
dollars on this bet that's all if I'm
gonna give you you want me to give you
10 you want to back out
no but remember I said the BET what we
made a stipulation I thought no did we
make stipulation work no because I took
you to call the stipulation saying that
you think right at the later things uh
no I know my problems gonna get knocked
out was that another fight we did be uh
is it Jake Paul yeah no Jake Paul Maybe
your boy's been right lately do you have
the Dustin prayer Michael Chandler do
you have I repeat I actually didn't get
no you picked Dustin I know but I didn't
get your pick I don't do pics you can't
do it not on that one oh yeah both of
them are my buddies
he's like dude because I give him the
shoes he's like oh this is so great man
you know I respect that you know I
looked up to you with all the stuff you
do because I do have to bring out you
pick against me I said when you fought
TJ I did TJ's a close buddy I'm biased
and [ __ ] yeah you know so I I do
apologize for Ben and then you know
picking TJ but to me it was a comeback
story I know I'm very close to TJ just
to be fully transparent music no I get
he was laughing
is going to actually mop the floor with
Wellington no but can you tell me what
you think is going to happen with Dustin
and Chandler in terms of strategy what
do you think is going to happen I don't
know Chandler frustrates when he knows
this we talked against the gate you
fight ago Dude get him into that brawl
last double his ass yes because you're
grappling you know he doesn't focus a
lot in grappling and nobody's done it
because everyone's worried about his
wrestling and he just wants to block
your ears is it because he doesn't want
to get tired or no he just doesn't want
he's gonna give it he don't want to
wrestle because wrestling's better than
Dustin's he can put dust on his back
you're saying uh challenge wrestling's
better channel is wrestling he's very
explosive wrestle at Missouri like stud
yeah
the other team was Woodley asking and uh
monsters so um I mean you could
definitely get Dustin now you can't do
it early that's Dustin's a vet so it's
gonna be tough take him down early yeah
but if you can get him to engage in that
fisticuffs and then blast up his blast
up was so athletic so athlete explosive
so does Chandler's a better wrestler
who's got better Jiu Jitsu poy but
challenge who's got better boxing
straight boxing straight like
technique-wise uh okay who's got better
kicks
poor
interesting power though Chandler all
day
Chandler one knockout power Channel yeah
yeah the only guy on this entire card
who hits hardened him is Alex Pierre not
saying a lot yeah
yeah
Dominic Reyes been a minute uh do you
know anything about Jon Jones he's
fighting Stipe when he was supposed to
find him December 10th and it's the
contract was up to steeping it's a
steepe thing it's not John thing John's
ready to go okay you'll get him next
year but ideally the UFC wants John vs
Francis so they're trying to figure out
the Francis deal before John doesn't
want to fight Francis he does he does
but Francis isn't under contract right
now Francis wants to fight Fury to do
his thing so what Francis wants is he
wants to fight Fury then John and you
see he's going no no no no you're going
to fight John and then we can talk yeah
and they're going no we want to
guarantee that I can fight outside who
would you picking that and which one
John John against everybody really yeah
John beats everybody
John beats every boy everybody yeah I
think his toughest matches Sierra gone
to his footwork but John take him down
yeah finish him I've seen John beat some
of the top heavyweights in the world
when he's cutting that 205.
yeah John John's a nightmare nightmare
yeah
because I think Cyril gone beats him
but I don't think Francis Nagano has an
answer to John's wrestling you think so
gandas Francis took Cyril down yeah
you stupid right no no I think oh but
I'm crazy about Cosmo pizza cereal
ground is way more dangerous
in a lot of ways better Striker no I
think no I mean Francis beat him so
France Francis out grappled him before
so he's a point he's a point fighter but
then if you engage he will knock you out
yeah but John for John it's all about
pretty calf he can't hit he can't take
the same punishment he took at like
heavyweight I'm gonna get this big
uh I think there's a number of things
that happened there yeah you know John's
ready to go the bottom line is John's
ready to go they want John Francis
trying to figure there's a lot of moving
Parts I don't know what happened with
Stipe because because John was like you
have the contract see if they sign it
and Steve's team didn't wanna
I don't know what's going on there yeah
did you hear uh uh my boy thug nasty
caught Rogan wants to debate him on Flat
Earth because he said the Earth is flat
and Rogue made some you know road you
can just shoot him yeah Brogan goes uh
that's stupid so then so then uh thug
nasty Bryce Mitchell goes he got it on
his Instagram was like I challenge you
to a debate you want to call me stupid
then prove to me I'm stupid because my
mom and all this Flat Earth so I'm like
that's that's not what you want Bryce no
do you want to hear it or yes Bryce
Mitchell yeah Savage no super Savage he
thinks the Earth is flat
okay
it's a shock in the common belief these
days I think he's just being silly no no
no no no you got to educate yourself
yeah since I'm on the show and we've got
about 10 years I've been following
communities that believe this it's my
buddy Bob it's probably before this yeah
well yeah here we go okay
I guess he seems to know hey I'm here to
call out Joe Rogan for talking crap
about me and talking crap about my mama
he's been doing it for too long me and
my mama will tell you right now this
Earth is flat it ain't moving around no
600 something thousand miles an hour
spinning a thousand miles an hour and
floating through the universe constantly
okay sounds very scientific it's fixed
and the stars and stuff rotate around us
the sun rotates around us okay and I can
prove right I would love to improve it
Joe Rogan because I'm tired of you
making fun of flat earthers and if
you're so confident come on and debate
me buddy because I'm tired of this crap
you're posting you want to post a video
today
um about a mathematician that says the
universe is local but it ain't real
what does that even mean that's funny
that's funny brother and the guy's
holding a trident in the picture they
don't think I'm crazy for thinking that
this is a religious thing he's holding a
trident a symbol of the devil they're
trying to feed you these lies to make
you think that science is right and that
God didn't create this universe the Big
Bang did okay I used to be an atheist
because I used to believe that
this universe was created by the big
bang I used to believe all that crap
from Neil deGrasse Tyson okay
interesting I'm just so sick and tired
of hearing your crap yo about Flat Earth
wow flat earthers being stupid well I'll
smoke you in a debate I will smoke you
okay you seem like a scientist because
you ain't got no proof gravity ain't
real it's density this paper
when it drops it's because it's more
dense than the air around it not because
of some magic wow so all of the
scientists are wrong but Bryce Mitchell
is right there's only proof of density
that's why hot air balloons float
because of hot air being less dense
gotcha okay not because of hot air
balloon
gravitational device and I will debate
you right to your face and I'm tired of
this crap that you're posting I'm tired
of you making fun of flat earthers
because you got one right here that will
bring it to you and I know you won't
accept this challenge I actually know I
don't know
but I bet you won't I bet you're sincere
he seems like a sweet guy but he's out
of his mouth he's a great guy no oh no
no he's not out of his mind that's just
his belief he's a great well no no no no
no no no no
no no you can't just you're not entitled
to your own facts it's like it's his
belief that's fine it's also people have
a lot of ignorant beliefs I mean you
could say that well but but there's also
like there's a lot of smart people that
believe there's this no no they're not
there's some smart people no no no
you're wrong no they're you're wrong I
guarantee there's some there's no
scientific people there's no people who
come from oh I can't see there's someone
with higher IQ than us that think
they're that's a very different thing
there are smart people who might be very
mistaken because they're not educated at
all in certain things there are a lot of
uneducated people that are way smarter
than I am what I'm trying to say is that
there's a tradition of science that so
the same science that allows us to
harness the magnetic field uh push us
beyond our biology with things like
Therapeutics when you go to a doctor and
your child God forbid has something like
cancer uh there are a lot of treatments
that that help that child live and and
put that child in remission uh sure the
things the things that the things that
allow for us to fly
um through the air at 600 miles an hour
in something that weighs engineering
sure all those things that is a
scientific tradition all the technology
goes into this phone we can just keep
going x-rays MRIs CAT scans I mean all
that stuff that's a scientific tradition
that all of us all of us benefit from
every day and science like Gene editing
and all these things continue to grow
and will push us so far beyond what we
think is possible
the same scientific tradition
that says the Earth is round and that
the Earth revolves around the Sun
is exactly what you benefit from all the
other science
okay so when you just say that that's
what I believe and I can debate you you
are saying that all the other science is
[ __ ] too you just are because those
scientists yes yes it is those
scientists would all look at you and say
first of all you're a young man you just
don't know the first thing about
anything you're talking about he hasn't
studied this stuff there is too much of
a rich intellectual and scientific
history and literature behind all of
this that that's been put to rest so
long ago in fact longer than than
anything I know of I mean the even the
ancient Greeks knew the Earth was
spherical not flat at least the ones
that were scientists so when somebody
comes out and says this stuff and they
can debate you and stuff and it's it's
obviously not something that I can
really entertain
and either with Joe or anybody else
you can't you can't you can't yeah I
don't know
if Joe's have their own beliefs but
you're not talking but I don't think you
can call them stupid because there are
some smart people that believe that I
don't know if I don't know anything
about price Mitchell I'm sure he's I'm
sorry it's a good dude I'm sure he's a
great guy I just told backbone I just
told you it seems like yeah that's not
that's not the point
that's not what I'm saying you can be a
great guy and a smart guy and be he
could be uninformed as far mostly
ignorant to that yeah but it means
grocery across the board there's some
smart people unfortunately that maybe
think the Earth is flat or there's some
smart people that you know I'm stupid
for saying listen Cove it's fake or the
Russia Wars fake but they might be
brilliant people in other aspects so
you're rejecting all of science is what
you're saying like that's always it's
like you can't just pick this one
particular instance you have to reject
all of science or nothing that's exactly
right you have to be consistent in your
thinking and when you benefit from from
the scientific tradition which is
essentially something that you can
measure measurable proof
um when uh when you fly you're talking
like I think there's this flash I know
I'm saying like like exactly things like
that that we use we communicate through
satellites and stuff like that all that
stuff uh you know I mean it's a thousand
reasons but yeah not somebody who's ever
exposed himself to that kind of thing
are you aware of the degree to which
this belief has had a Resurgence this is
what worries me about the internet okay
you you you can literally you can
literally find your own truth
confirmation bias whatever whatever I
don't think that's harmless I don't no
no it's a problem because you can get
people and I'm not saying it's about
price I'm I love Bryson he's entitled
his opinions but there's some people
that if they want to they can go down
that Rebel of whatever it is and then
that's where you get people shooting up
Cosmo pizza or whatever because they you
can find the confirmation bias there
could be you know uh Chin's actually a
robot yes you can do some research and
there's me some article and then there's
gonna be a group and then get
like-minded people next you know like
wow all you think like I do and then man
this must be real and then you start
with the Earth is flat next thing you
know you know uh Obama's a lizard person
it goes down a deep deep road man I
actually saw that with an individual
friend of mine who started with the Flat
Earth and then like two years later I'm
like oh you're a full-blown white
supremacist now like used to be like an
artsy you know sound guy yeah and piece
by piece go down a weird Road it just
tends so you see these uh comments it's
so interesting so this is a different
video where he actually explains it if
you guys want to watch no it's okay I
don't know I mean you guys should
especially I I've debated the number one
yeah [ __ ] Brian
but that guy was good at what he was
saying no he's I listened to a real
scientist just absolutely and he kept
ignoring it and he was like he goes wait
stop do you hear what I said he's like
and he would go on to something else I
mean I David Weiss I mean I know myself
I've studied this stuff when I went to
school but I couldn't even debate a
flight out there today they would
probably because they're so interested I
I talked to David who like he had all
these things look this is so silly that
I would never have the debate like I did
it on Conspiracy social club because
it's fun to do I like it disassembly but
you know no Sam doesn't know but I mean
it's fun to do I like it it's I get it I
like that I I do feel like thug nasty
there's no a little tongue-in-cheek
there he's kind of he's kind of having
fun you don't know him you're so far off
you just don't know him but he seems so
Charmed like like the way he delivered
that it was extremely charming and I'm
laughing just organic he's a good dude
how stupid he is like he just has a way
with words
I don't think ignorance is harm harmless
I think ignorance uh cuts a lot of times
across the Spectrum and I think if you
are that impressionable and you get
enough people like that uh history would
prove that things don't work out so well
so but that's in everything politics
everything everything this information
all that [ __ ] but you know bright
said great but when he came on the show
he was like defending Bryce he was like
no I'm not defense I'm not the way he
thinks and I'm talking about this as a
phenomenon right I don't think it's
harmless yeah but you keep saying you
think he's joking and I'm telling you
don't know him well then he's very well
he's very very religious and he seems
he's not religious I think he's
religious but he's also a very
conspiracy guy he just said it on did
you not hear him no he said he said I
he's not balls deep in
church
I'm with you you this is the first time
here this kid talk I just heard I'm
telling you that I'm very well he's on
the show and he goes I just want to be
censored do whatever you want then I had
to educate him because he was talking
about mass shootings how it's a
government thing hold on hold on I said
he goes come on man you think one guy
was able to kill those whatever
five-year-olds with a AR-15 I guess
Bryce I have a five-year-old they were
they were terrified dude it was and it
was also transgenuate dude all right I
said that's your entire opinion but
that's where misinformation that came
out days ago that that wasn't really oh
and he goes oh damn I didn't know I need
to look in there I go that's the problem
you got to look at get all the actual
facts because it wasn't a transient
shooter it was one shooter right and
it's not a government like team doing
that's that's what I mean by being yeah
but he does this stuff and you know he
gets a fan base and that's his thing but
it's for him it's not an act you know
what I'm saying like what's his uh
what's his ranking in the UFC he's seven
probably yeah top ten I think yeah he
has a big fight coming up too who's he
fighting but the 45 here he's finding
this big fight though he's undefeated
two both of them are undefeated 45 right
45 45
he can debate Rogan
he and what he can debate Rogan damn I
don't think so I don't think Rogan's
entertaining that I think Rogan because
he knows he'll get smoked yeah I don't
think he'll get a thing from Rogan out
of that yeah
but yeah can you imagine if Rogan
problem that had like uh uh Neil
deGrasse Tyson there with him that would
be amazing I mean people it wouldn't no
I'm saying people would definitely you
don't want that for Bryce no I don't
[ __ ] views that's a problem with the
word too like for views like you to
embarrass prize no but it's good for
Bryce to learn that stuff it's not it's
good for Bryce to have a conversation
with Neil deGrasse Tyson in private yeah
you don't want to embarrass somebody on
air yeah that's not cool doing reviews
as long as he has a conversation with
them then I agree with I think you
should just have a conversation by the
way Bryce is the one who's asking for a
debate yeah no I know and I get to your
point ignorance is bliss you don't want
to debate Rogan trust me I've I've been
right on some things that you don't want
to argue with them it's a nightmare yeah
they got the guy's a Savage I also
believe though if he did a conversation
one-on-one with uh Neil deGrasse Tyson
the people that are flat Earth there's
and let's say Bryce lost that there
maybe no they'd be like oh something
happened he gave me money or something
yeah he did it on air they could all see
how he reacts if he knows something my
podcast Conspiracy social club is it's a
very interesting thing yes I talk to
people who are make their living
basically denying certain things do you
think they actually believe are they
doing it for the money because once you
dip your toe and you get that fan base
you can't yeah you can't get out but you
also can't pick it you're also making
money you can't be like well the Earth
is flat but then also like you have to
100 well this guy like so there yeah I
would say that whenever you ask them
some questions that they can't answer
they'll say sometimes they'll go I'm
just asking questions and it's like but
that's not what you are doing you're
actually but you know what you're right
so you what happens is you develop a
community you develop a following you
start making money and you gotta you
gotta hold on to that the biggest
problem with Scientists too is like a
lot of times scientists have an entire
Theory right they they teach courses
they write books and someone comes along
and disproves the theory and now that's
science right yeah you decide the first
thing is you got to be doubt is a big
part of Science and you have to always
be willing to change your hypothesis
based on on new evidence and sometimes
that happens but sometimes you have a
tenure ship you've written books you
teach classes on it and now what now so
what a lot of people a lot of times do
is they just pretend it didn't exist
nothing to see here and they keep going
but overall it's but then also for the
confirmation bias is like when that gets
disapproved like to all of it it's like
politics right they get something like
so all of them are like Jesus Christ no
yeah
it's a weird world it's fun but yet I
agree it's dangerous yeah or it's
already it's always existed and you can
now find your community but there wasn't
social media yeah I just think it's
interesting that I think Republicans so
so election denial would be considered a
conspiracy you know you can come yeah
both sides though yeah both sides Al
Gore both sides did are always like
denying elections
the White House Press Secretary always
yeah the left and the right is always
always talking about first thing they go
through yeah but what was funny was the
Trump uh loyalists did not fare well and
a lot of people think that people just
were turned off by that they were like
dude I you know you scare me a little
bit because you know there's no there's
just isn't enough evidence and you're
talking about election denial and you're
and you're such a trump Acolyte and
people were like just not most
independent voters are like I'm just not
with that crazy [ __ ] but I think in
Republicans are I called up there's
Republicans then there's Maga and they
they have to like get away from it
there's a difference those DeSantis
he said I'm Republican I'm not Maga I
don't want the Maga crew no I'm good man
yeah you're trying to separate you too
far from many people
because then it's like all right do you
deny all elections you know yeah
the things that you won hey B can we
take another break dude we could talk in
politics bro well I need my brain dude
I'll tell you some of those politicians
last night campaigning you would have
won got some nootropics kind of your
friends out on it listen on it has a
nootropic on the market it's called
Alpha Brain it's their Flagship you guys
heard of it look everybody from Joe
Rogan to Brennan's job you name it takes
it the the it is it is clearly something
you have to try to understand whether or
not it works
how do you know it works they're gonna
try it you'll see what happens and
here's the thing there's no risk
involved if you don't like it they give
you full refund you can keep the Alpha
Brain that's how confident on it is of
Alpha Brain the nootropics they're the
best on the market also if you're you
know if you're kind of worried about
caffeine it's caffeine free daddy it is
caffeine it's free right so all you got
to do is go to onnit.com
f-a-t-k all right or you can go to
Walmart pickup Alpha Brain but the show
Walmart yep Alpha Brain contains amino
acid and plant compounds that promote
the brain's release of alpha waves which
are associated with get this with
greater creativity and productivity yep
at the same time it supports
neurotransmitters chemicals that relay
information in and from the brain so if
coffee and energy drinks caffeine baby
yep.com yep on it.com f-a-t-k Tempest
enough not only Alpha Brain but the
entire on its site you got training gear
Warrior bars protein bars krill oil fish
oil multivitamins protein bars protein
powder on it.com f-a-t-k 10 off now
let's get back to the program
the things that you won uh best news of
the week Kane Velasquez yes bail whoa
yeah so he's with his family right now
that's great no way yep million dollar
bill and the judge is actually really
cool eight months dude same judge no
different judge and you're right about
this man I told you you said if it was a
dude I don't know if you said it on your
off care but it was a dude it'd be a
little different yeah and this is
completely different yes so that's his
statement right there
if somebody wants to read it different
is he takes a rational approach to him
so he said I would not release you if I
was convinced that upon a release at
this time a month later that you would
be in be a danger to Harry primarily
um
if you are as devoted to a husband
father I'm confident and have to believe
you will not jeopardize anything that
would take you away from your son your
daughter or your or your family I hope
you don't prove me wrong and then uh
Kane respond I want your honor yeah how
dope is that from what I heard that once
this thing hits trial there's gonna be
some info that comes out you think yeah
that's people close to sources say that
that's it poor Kane man this is when he
was released he made a little statement
eight months too let me see this and you
see the picture of his wife hugging him
she's like crying it was yeah pretty
powerful
foreign
I guess it is the bay it's up there he
takes it off right here though oh yeah I
can't wait to get off a bit
he probably had no problems
hey how you doing Kane
how's it feel to be out
let's go blessed you though
um ready to go home
you gonna be with the loved ones family
friends and um make something positive
of this whole situation
anything else came
yes thank you to everybody who had my
support
um I love all of you
um
yeah man just always continue to be
better as a person
always do good things
um and yeah just make something positive
in this terrible situation you know my
family and I will
we're gonna do that sure man
the energy from that report is off the
charts
okay you know the reporter was
respectful he's probably scared too
yeah talk about being going through some
[ __ ]
the fight starts you know now the fight
starts yeah Etc I don't know so I looked
it up I was like wondering how long is
his bail couldn't find out but for now
he's it's until trial which is the first
one's on November 26th I think two
months in County Jail is that Arizona no
San Jose oh yeah yeah that's why it was
tough to do California yeah California
yeah
but you're right him in jail I'm sure
he's perfectly fine yeah yeah he's gonna
be fun
and that's the judge by the way so shout
out to this guy oh yeah shout out to uh
Arthur That's My Boy Arthur
Arthur Boca Negra so there's a Powerball
ticket that was sold in California for 2
billion I think believe that's the
highest ever right yeah so 2 billion and
uh turns out that it's the father-in-law
oh no the place that sold it is like a
tire gas station place
do you know uh NFL star domada pekko yes
I guess his father-in-law is the one
that sold the ticket at the shop so he
automatically wins a million bucks oh
wow really that's the cool thing about
yeah like liquor stores where they get a
percentage or a certain lump fever it
comes from your wow that's so cool so
he's a million person that won I just
like is there any way I can just blur my
face on every interview so my family and
friends don't find out I think there's a
way to get away with it no [ __ ] people
wore masks and stuff like that oh I'd
wear just they'll find out though people
will all go find out Oh you mean when
you win the whole thing the biggest uh
well because you could take the lump sum
up front which I think they said was
like 996 million up front or you can get
paid out over 30 years and it's like and
get like 1.5 billion but just take the
996 million up front and then invest
invest in all the money in the world
yeah man I mean [ __ ] that's a lot of
money taxes right
good problem to have though
this is a cool video this is a shark
jumping into a boat oh boy it's a Mako
it's like one of the fastest sharks
there goes jumps right in the boat it's
like a 300 something pound shark that's
so cool
now did it jump because it's been it's
it's caught or I think it was feeding
this shark's like what in that that's so
weird
yeah luckily everyone was behind the
boat so I'm more worried about the shark
the poor guy I care about you can't
breathe right now he was able to wiggle
his way back into the ocean would he go
under the I don't know they didn't show
the in the video but it says it went
back in some crazy they're shooting 46
miles because of the fastest shark damn
when you make up they look like many
great whites yeah
I don't know if I show you what this is
gonna be so lame but all right what
Wimbledon I didn't know this before but
you have to wear all white and women had
to wear white underwear and white skirts
and some women had periods so this would
be a really bad you know thing it was a
an actual rule
it'd be bad for me other than brown I'm
like yeah I Gotta Wear I don't wipe my
butts changing next year and I was like
I thought I could have sworn Serena wore
black outfits and stuff like that but
then I Googled it at Wimbledon it's all
white strict rules yeah old school too
old school it used to be if you were in
a country club or whatever you had to
wear white when you played tennis that
was it why underwear too that's kind of
like what the hell yeah oh boy so
Jessica Simpson put out a video recently
it's like an ad and then people were
thinking she's something something's
with her so I'll just play it real quick
let me know if you guys know the same
thing I'm Jessica Simpson and welcome to
my daughter Birdie's room designed by
Pottery Barn kids and a little bit it's
an actual commercial I was really drawn
to the geometric prints and the color
scheme
this really to me is Bernie's
personality
thank you everyone for checking out the
adorable room of 30 Mae Johnson
maybe a little awkward too where they're
like can you redo it and then she's like
okay and then she started maybe getting
her head talking like a robot a little
bit yeah yeah she's like she was that
interested in it can I see the other
pictures of her yeah
she's down here so she lost a ton of
weight now yeah she was a big girl yeah
yeah look at her wow yeah she's just
gorgeous man and person and back back in
the day it was like cheese she was super
hot back in the day nothing better when
her sister went outside
three times on a Monday Sunday
but now you know most people no not most
but a lot of people were like what
worried like what is going on here she
looks good when she puts on weight
though I guarantee it like it all goes
to her button boobs second goes my
button boobs no I don't want her chin
and tummy I didn't see the big shot big
man
yeah she got big
let me see
just I remember back in the day I was
like what oh yeah just shoot you know it
was like her Britney Spears Christina
Aguilera had a poster of her in my dorm
room yikes I was probably working with
her at the time
she was like Jesus yeah see she got
pretty big on that you see what we're
working with there
um but she really really put on weight
no but then she really was pretty
overweight for a little while too like
right here you can tell
yeah I don't have a problem with it I
think she was probably still hot as [ __ ]
I mean you know it's a lot of weight
she's hot
yeah and she lost it though she was
crushing it yeah she looks good tapeworm
oh see here's another picture too okay
it's changed quite a bit yeah either way
she's she's a very pretty girl that's
what it is some people yeah some people
yo-yo you don't yo-yo no you're pretty
good no matter what I do I mean you stay
pretty consistent yeah
um but that's because you're a Nazi
about the way you eat no even when I let
myself lose I make it a little heavier
but I never no I don't yo-yo I can be
like John you don't a lot of people
yo-yo man oh what's this beautiful chest
bring this [ __ ] up Mark Harley's list
this guy's one of the best chests I've
seen oh my gosh oh he has a weird uh
so that's like a it's like oh it's a
sternum right you have that fixed
why would you want to fix Brian can you
not pull it down I know it are you
implying there's something it looks like
a human it looks like a shark yeah
it looks unhealthy
if he's born that way then but if he's
fine do you just kind of roll with it
because you want to have major surgery I
guess you'd have to push your open heart
surgery yeah
you know set it yeah it's a lot of but
if you put a lot of muscle on that might
not look that bad
hmm
this one I think it'll find funny
these are parents doing a tackling drill
with their kids about border that's
great
and what happens if those little dudes
light the pairing up oh [ __ ] those kids
are coming full too oh wow oh damn the
parents are actually really good my mom
took this [ __ ] out of the kid they
really are
oh this kid's smart he didn't oh okay
smart and then yeah oh
they have this Branch like in your face
yeah the one kid with good tackling for
him oh yes he broke down
any particular ones 20. what's 20. 20.
when you just go down oh have you seen
that new Doc on Netflix the killer Sally
no it's uh she was a bodybuilder and her
husband was like on the verge of he did
compete Mr Olympia plays like 15th and
uh she killed him shot him killed him
why uh he was like super abusive but she
was super aggro like aggressive and he
would like beat her but she was also
kind of crazy it's a three-part series
it's so [ __ ] good damn yeah yeah and
then the whole the whole thing is
they're saying because this was in 95
she shot him on Valentine's Day because
he was going to leave her and she was
like obsessed with him but he had
another girlfriend so he came back to
the house and she shot him with a
shotgun but the forensic is like hold on
you said he was chasing he was going to
hit you trying to protect yourself from
the kid so he shot him yeah they go well
the shotgun was located where she liked
the bedroom so they went through and
that's what [ __ ] her
they found she went and got the shotgun
they were talking he turned around she
shot him close range right in the
stomach oh my God she had to go back and
reload the truck into the room as he's
like on the ground and I shot him in the
face
but you watch it it's tough because they
have people on there like things are
different now because she was so abused
like she was defending herself like over
the years she would probably get away
now
he was beating the [ __ ] out of her yeah
back then they didn't have the you know
yeah the information and [ __ ] it's super
interesting yeah super interesting I
gotta watch that it's good yeah and also
to see how she was making money because
she was like the breadwinner pretty much
by doing these like wrestling videos of
like beating dudes up so like that was
like only fans back in the days like is
she hot hey you
because back then they were huge or was
she huge she got pretty big halfway
through she was like I was only an
anavon like my girls that's animal I'm
like no yeah all sorts of stuff but at
the time the murder good muscle on the
time of the murder they found killer
killer Sally on the time of the murder
they found like seven different steroids
in his body right he's Mr Computer yeah
seven yeah in hers they only found one
okay
they're both they're both Marines too
they're both in the army
well it's just pretty big especially
back then it's a big girl yeah yeah and
that's her boyfriend the husband husband
uh he was jacked yeah she looks like
she's she's put on some and then she
there she is out
uh no that's not her no no
she was pretty before she started out in
for her chin growing [ __ ] yeah
he was Jack City yeah he's Jack City
there she is right there right she's out
now that's her out yeah
so it's cheated up dude oh cheeked up
definitely cheeked up
can't have a flat ass to me a female
bodybuilder wow look at that man
that turned out yeah she had 20 years 25
years hard time
you guys should watch though she's like
lifting people I'm 100 gonna watch it
yeah
these two guys you want to break the
Guinness and are you ready also for the
audio listeners it's uh two dudes one
guy's bouncing on his the other dude's
head while the other guy's walking up
the stairs yeah that's crazy what the
[ __ ] and the user had to bounce
it's just head on head when they start
walking which is insane holy [ __ ] and
the guy oh this is my [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey dude well he's got jogging he might
be late for class [ __ ] that guy he's
like take a minute look at what's going
on in front of you I don't know what's
more impressive the guy on top of guy on
bottom I was gonna say dude two plus two
flights of stairs we gotta get look at
how strong the Dude down there is
go go go go go go go go go look how
strong that mother is
we can do it that's crazy look the on
Top's balancing that's crazy you can do
it and I like how it's like what is the
world record one flight of stairs
let's go
let's go for you oh my god
let's go this [ __ ] is strong as
[ __ ] the kidneys all the record is
nothing it's nothing
think about how strong his legs NASA we
can do it I feel the core probably got
on top here we go and they both have
both they both have flat tops
these are both very strong mothers and
there's like splits upside down splits
yes yes they're twins
did you guys get off now you guys have
just witnessed history
and you guys see how they have flat tops
oh man nobody was there everyone's like
okay we didn't even know this is a
record that's crazy and he's in which he
gets into that position is to stop I
don't like that dumbass you have to walk
by
no no what a dick world record here like
bro like take a minute wherever you're
going can be yeah anyway that guy's I
hate that guy
give us one more Channel all right
gotta do to all them Nikes y'all
and them Adidas ain't about what you
wear it's about who word
how y'all gonna denounce that man cause
he a junior we all Jews
we all Jews
y'all Gotta Throw It Away man burn it
this guy's burning all this Adidas
tonight so wait he also works with Nike
too uh Kyrie Irving who they said
yeah he's a bit of a
he actually took all the a lot of heat
from Kanye Connie should pay Kyrie
Irving's a royalty yeah
because they you already bought the
shoes
so how does that affect Nike damn yeah I
I mean okay
well
one guy burned his shoes I think yeah
more than one but yeah I don't know but
the thing is Adida owns the design of
the Yeezys so for the slides they own
the design so kind of can't just go
somewhere else to make the same shoes
he'll come up with new ones but Adidas
is going to continue to sell those oh
they are I doubt the easy fans buy them
though the EU fans aren't going to buy
them the natural he didn't he apologize
now kind of yeah he's walking it all
back yep still but if you buy it now
well Kanye doesn't get the money for it
so I mean you can buy him nothing
well not yet now they're saying like off
the market so the value on Kanye's
actual Yeezys Adidas have gone through
the roof through the roof oh I'm sure
but he'll make him he's he's getting
distribution across these so make it
himself new design
might be more fire a little fire under
his ass
uh I'm I'm not burning Yeezys and Nikes
but I will be in Houston Houston
November 10th through the 12th that's
this Thursday Friday Saturday I have an
appearance at the specs downtown Houston
it's on my social media for the exact
address so Houston Texas Houston Improv
Europe this Thursday Friday Saturday
next week Friday Saturday only Milwaukee
Milwaukee improvs Friday Saturday only
Providence Rhode Island December 1st
through the third that's almost sold out
so get your remaining tickets DC Improv
Washington DC I will be at Cosmos Pizza
as well December 15th to 17th uh DC
Improv give your tickets at thick
boy.com that sweet tiger thick will be
available in Houston Milwaukee and DC so
make sure you get that sweet nectar come
see your boy at specs this Saturday from
noon to two specs downtown Houston
Brian Callan is at the comedy zone this
week Thursday Friday Saturday Thursday
Friday Saturday Addison Texas
right now I know November 17 18 19. if
you're around Naples Florida off the
comedy club December one two three and
four doing a Sunday for the first time
you have tapeworms guys I got tape worms
all right kids love you we're out